nous sommes le 5 septembre 2016 bonsoir
et bienvenue pour cette toute première
édition du 7 8 les invités du lundi au
jeudi nous donnons la parole à ceux qui
font l actualité aujourd'hui vous
entendrez bertrand de créer le président
du medef des yvelines le syndicat des
patrons tenait il ya quelques jours son
université d'été à jouy en josas rendez
vous extrêmement politisé à quelques
mois de l'élection présidentielle
alors qu'attendent les chefs
d'entreprise
rencontre également avec michel de
kerchove c'est la présidente de sos
victimes 78è les récents attentats ont
obligé l'association à renforcer son
aide aux victimes nous verrons comment
cette association agit au quotidien mais
pour le moment il est question de cette
nouvelle année scolaire cela concerne
300 4514 élèves pour les yvelines qu'il
soit écoliers collégiens ou encore l
lycéens serge clément le directeur
académique des yvelines était avec nous
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau à
cette année scolaire sera sous haute
surveillance en raison des risques
d'attentats cette année sera donc
marquée par de nombreux changements
également on va y revenir et sur cet
aspect sécuritaire tout d'abord on parle
de deux tests en grandeur réelle
grandeur nature pour tous ces élèves est
ce que tout est presque tout est déjà
planifié tout est prêt et d'autant plus
que notre département bénéficie déjà
d'une expérience puisque sur les plan
particulier de mise en sûreté nous avons
réalisé ce depuis plusieurs années déjà
100% d'exercice de la maternelle au
lycée nous avons repréciser tout cela
avec les services de l'état de la
sécurité civile en présence de monsieur
le préfet le mercredi 24 août dernier et
nous allons rencontrer très
prochainement l'union des maires des
yvelines le conseil départemental le
conseil régional pour voir comment
coordonner cet ensemble de mesures à la
fois en termes d' exercice puisque 3
vous l'avez dit ce sont prévues dantin
avant les congés de tout ça qui portera
justement sur un exercice attentats
intrusion est ce qu'il y aura un
accompagnement également pour les élèves
un accompagnement peut être
psychologique pour ne pas les effrayer
et ne pas effrayer non plus leurs
parents c'est la grande question c'est à
dire que sur sept ce scénario 1
d'exercice il faut qu'on soit y est très
très vigilants notamment pour les jeunes
enfants de maternelle il se trouve que
là aussi notre département et est déjà
très avancé nous avons proposé un
certain nombre de situations anneaux à
nos enseignants qui ont été d'ailleurs
diffusé sur l'ensemble du territoire
national sur lesquels nous nous
appuierons pour accompagner les équipes
et les former vous allez les aider ces
élèves les accompagner pour pas créer de
psychose en quelque sorte au moment de
ses différents tests en marge de cette
actualité il ya aussi de beaucoup
nouveauté pour cette rentrée scolaire
vous vous dites d'ailleurs plutôt que
cette année plutôt stimulante voilà je
recherchais voter on vous disait cette
année sera stimulante vous êtes
optimiste en cette rentrée d'abord je
suis optimiste parce que on a il faut le
dire des équipes pédagogiques de grande
qualité dans le département je disais
tout à l'heure en présence du président
bédié combien ce département fait
réussir ses élèves avec des résultats
qui sont les premiers 1
dans l'académie de versailles avec des
progrès qu'il faut encore amplifier dans
certains secteurs du département mais
avec la réforme du collège avec les
programmes qui aujourd'hui en cycle 2
c'est à dire en fin d'école
primaire cycle 2 et cycle iii se met en
place nous avons également avec le
brevet des collèges qui va bouger à la
session 2010 est nous avons de nombreux
chantiers qui nous mobilise des uns des
autres en marge de ces différentes
actualités une rentrée aussi sous le
signe des partenariats notamment
culturel il ya beaucoup de projets qui
sont prévues d'un partenariat avec le
château de versailles par exemple
partenariat avec le château de
versailles avec d'autres d'autres
théâtres d'autres scènes du département
la lanterne à rambouillet avec la
volonté que ce soit demande à
rambouillet ou à versailles d'avoir une
des partenariats extrêmement avancé et
aboutie qui mobilise le maximum d'élèves
comme on a pu le faire avec plus de
12000 élèves
dernière sur une exposition en
partenariat avec un projet en
partenariat avec le château de
versailles sur on n'y voit rien mais et
puis sur le plan sportif peut-être aussi
parce qu'il ya cette ryder cup qui
approche et ce sera aussi à saint
quentin en yvelines qui va être forcé
forcément impacter fortement impacté
pour cette ryder cup il ya des choses
qui sont prévus aussi alors il ya un
très fort engagement évidemment de la
sfi comme on vit aujourd'hui avec le
président laugier déjà une expérience
très très abouti au niveau du premier
degré qui a permis la pratique du golf
mais aussi des documents pédagogiques
qui viennent soutenir cette pratique
dans les classes et qu'on voudrait
étendre à des écoles mais aussi à des
collèges du département et c'est un
projet que nous avons finalisé avec le
conseil départemental pour les dernières
minutes de cet entretien j'aimerais
qu'on aborde la question des des
enseignants aussi parce qu'il ya cette
jeune grève est annoncée dès le 8
septembre vous leur dites quoi aux
enseignants la réforme des collèges qui
pose problème et puis les créations de
postes on y reviendra mais d'abord je
leur fais confiance
une totale confiance ce sont eux qui ont
l'intelligence de cette réforme ce sont
eux qui ont l'expérience et la
connaissance des élèves ils s'y sont
préparés beaucoup sont déjà engagés sur
toutes les nouvelles formes qui sont
préconisées que ce soit les fameux
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire où l'aide
personnalisée et nous sommes dans une
logique d'accompagnement et de confiance
des équipes avec les chefs
d'établissements de manière à la fois à
les rassurer à les sécuriser et puis
leur dire que la réforme aujourd'hui
rentrer dans une phase concrète et que
nous allons continuer à les accompagner
et à faire qu'il y ait ces échanges
professionnels de manière à réussir et
surtout faire réussir nos élèves
davantage encore de nos élèves et sur le
nombre d'enseignants le gouvernement a
beaucoup communiqué en cette rentrée la
mine isolée ducation sur les créations
de postes pendant ce quinquennat
forcément avec les élections qui
approchent ça semble assez logique ce
genre de communication mais sur le
terrain concrètement il ya eu des
créations de postes pour les yvelines
par exemple alors pour les yvelines ce
sont 123 postes et qui ont été données à
notre département vous faites le rapport
puisque nous avons un peu moins de 15
cents élèves supplémentaires attendus
nous avons beaucoup insisté sur le
premier degré avec notamment des mesures
en faveur des élèves qui rencontrent le
plus de difficultés sur des territoires
qui sont des territoires sensibles nous
avons consacré 75 65 de ses emplois mais
aussi avec une attention très forte sur
les territoires ruraux puisque le
département est aussi une dimension
rurale forte de manière à améliorer à la
fois les performances des élèves avec le
dispositif plus de maîtres queux de
classe améliorer aussi la scolarisation
précoce de de nos enfants et améliorer
autant que faire se peut la situation du
remplacement qui est un sujet
extrêmement sensible auquel les parents
s'en sont attentifs et demandeur donc un
ensemble de mesure 123 postes pour cette
seule rentrée merci serge clément d'être
venu commenter cette rentrée on vous
souhaite une bonne année forcément une
bonne année scolaire vous étiez le
premier invité de cette suite la
nouvelle version pour cette rentrée sur
tv fils et nous poursuivrons à présent
avec un autre invité que nous sommes
allés rencontrer les questions
d'économie à présent le medef vient de
refermer vous le savez sa traditionnelle
université dans une université d'été
dans les yvelines c'est à jouy en josas
à quelques mois des élections
législatives et surtout présidentielle
les chefs d'entreprise entendait faire
passer des messages aux candidats floral
parfait sur place avec bertrand de créer
le président de l'antenne lilloise du
medef
nous sommes à jouy en josas au campus
d'acheter pour l'université d'été du
medef 2016 avec bertrand du cray bonjour
à vous vous êtes le président du medef
des yvelines alors votre votre avis sur
cette université d'été 2016 qu'est ce
que vous pensez qu est-ce que cela
qu'est ce qu'on apprend aujourd'hui
c'est surtout un moment de rencontre
c'est c'est ça se passe après les
vacances
généralement on invite des hommes
politiques eux
déjà l'entreprise bien sûr qu'ils
donnent leur grande tendance donc c'est
toujours un moment
moi je trouve très très sympa pour deux
raisons
parce que hein on a une analyse sur ce
qui s'est passé dans l'année et on a de
la prospective sur ce qui va se passer
en plus il ya peu de l'actualité avec
les primaires et cetera donc c'est
toujours quelque chose de très
intéressant alors justement est-ce qu'on
n'a pas trop parlé politique et pas
assez d'économies à cette université du
medef 2016 je pense que c'est intimement
liés c'est justement
l'entreprise et mis au coeur de la
politique enfin tout au moins dans les
promesses des candidats on pourrait
croire à travers les promesses qu'ils
nous font mais reste à savoir si des
attentions seront suivies que nos
politiques ont une vraie prise de
conscience qu' on ne peut pas se passer
de l'entreprise que l'entreprise est le
fer de lance est le moteur de
l'entreprise france
et justement les différentes
propositions des politiques y sont
justement pour la primaire qu'est ce que
vous en penser ce qu'il ya des choses
que vous retenez qui ont peut-être
retenu plus d'attention que les autres
elles sont je dirais qu elles sont
magnifiques mais seconde est habitués
ici moi j'ai vu un prémice nous dira
jamais l'entreprise
on est habitués à ce qu'on nous fasse
des promesses alors on va pas bouder le
plaisir
on est content d'être entendu on serait
très content que soient suivies
d'actions là je dirais qu'aujourd'hui on
les implique qu'ils ont clientes et
qu'ils ont défilé sur les plateaux ont
fait des promesses qui nous intéresse
effectivement quand j'entends monsieur
fillon ne pas de liberté de liberté
d'entreprendre liberté de traiter les
accords de liberté dans leur travail
quand j'entends monsieur sarkozy qui le
dit qui veut faire 100 millions d'euros
d'économies les vans public pour
justement baisser les chefs d'entreprise
je vous dise parfaitement d'accord avec
eux
là haut je resterai à peu réservés c'est
ce sont des promesses la priorité là
pour les entreprises pour les pme pour
les tpe à cette rentrée c'est justement
voilà de se débarrasser dans certains
carcans administratifs et bien sûr c'est
clair ça c'est clair savait il ya deux
choses qui passent c'est le poids des
charges le poids des charges bois de la
poule et la lourdeur administrative
c'est c'est clairement l'insécurité
aussi l'insécurité c'est pour pouvoir
faire développer nos entreprises nous
faut la sérénité quand même une dernière
question avant de finir cet entretien la
relance en 2010 est vous y croyez
s'il croit alors attendez il ya des
facteurs qui sont
extérieur tonnerre
je pense clairement la population défi
entreprises nation volontaire
prête à défier devait danger eux
ses vents une question de confiance la
question de confiance si
la relance ne viendra que par nous que
par les entreprises en grande partie
parle
beaucoup ri jeu
je vous dirige y croit toujours j'y
crois toujours pas ce que je crois je
crois c'est trouver la vitalité coup les
entrepreneurs de france à vouloir se
développer nous mêmes et donc la
développer très bien merci beaucoup
ouverte ronds de christian
un tout autre sujet à présent les
victimes du terrorisme ont besoin
d'accompagnement une fois le travail de
la cellule des d'un terreau ministériel
aide aux victimes terminer ce sont les
associations qui prennent le relais sur
le terrain là dans les yvelines par
exemple sos victimes a été obligé de
renforcer cette action entre soutien
psychologique et accompagnement dans les
démarches administratives une interview
menée par nicolas kirillovitch
alors l'association sos victimes 78 a
été créé il ya presque trente ans en
1990 dans un premier temps pour
accueillir les victimes d'infractions
pénales les personnes qui font l'objet
d'agressions qui en sont victimes
d'actions de la route des escroqueries
etc et petit à petit bien nos activités
ont évolué parce que l'actualité la
nécessité notamment la prise en charge
des accidents collectifs les crashs
aériens et autres et au plus récemment
les attentats depuis début 2015 nous
avons dans chacune de nos associations
un référent terrorisme qui est formé
spécifiquement au terrorisme et nous
avons donc 7 cette offre qui est faite
aux victimes dans le cas du terrorisme
c'est à dire que les coordonnées nous
sont communiquées toujours par le même
bien et nous prenons contact avec les
victimes et nous leur proposons un
accompagnement global psychologique
juridique et sociale aussi si elles en
ont besoin notre fédération est
également organismes de formation donc
avec la chancellerie nous avons organisé
la formation de nos membres et nos
référents terrorisme parce que c'est une
prise en charge assez particulière
surtout que les actes de terrorisme sont
différents les uns des autres le
bataclan ce n'est pas la même chose que
nice donc avec des victimes qui ont des
traumatismes différents donc nous avons
cette prise en charge qui est fait avec
des personnes formées véritablement ce
soit les juristes ou les psychologues et
qui peuvent accompagner le mieux
possible les victimes et éviter qu'elles
aient des stress post traumatique qui
s'enkystent malheureusement trop
longuement les éviers ne sont pas
exclu du terrorisme temps parce que ça
se passe sur son territoire comme à
magnanville avec ceux comme jeune couple
de policiers mais aussi parce que les
actes se déroule en dehors des yvelines
mais pour des personnes qui habitent
dans les ive et donc à ce moment-là nous
intervenons et nous avons depuis janvier
2015 une centaine de personnes en charge
au titre de tous les actes de terrorisme
qui se sont déroulés soit en france soit
également en tunisie également à
ouagadougou à bruxelles nous avons
également des yvelinois qui ont été pris
en charge par ce qu'ils étaient présents
sur ses actes sur c'est sur ces lieux où
des acteurs sont connus
c'est la fin de ce premier set 8 les
invités chaque soir donc dorénavant pour
la première diffusion en direct à 18h 15
du lundi au jeudi et replay disponible
dès à présent bien sûr sur notre site
internet les programmes qui se
poursuivaient sur notre antenne